NSA bulk data collection might be
changing but there's one area of
surveillance that has gone largely
unchallenged police surveillance cops
around the country not only have access
to military-style weaponry but
increasingly military technology when it
comes to monitoring and tracking people
Police Department's around the country
work with federal agencies to do what's
called predictive policing trying to
stop a crime before it even happens
think Minority Report and there are a
lot of new techniques and technologies
one is a piece of software that's
literally called predictive policing or
shred pull and it's used in dozens of
cities around the country
it takes location data on past crimes to
try and see where there will be more and
it gathers massive amounts of
information about that location then
there's facial recognition where a
police officer can just take a photo of
you with an iPad and then immediately
run it through a database to see who you
are that's already being used in Seattle
and Tampa there's also street lamps yeah
street lamps that record conversations
like ones in Las Vegas although police
there say that even though they have the
technology they're not actually using it
right we've also got license plate
scanners location tracking devices
surveillance drones and automated social
media monitoring then there's something
called behavioral recognition technology
that is able to track all of your
movements through a city station on
surveillance cameras that was most
notoriously used against protesters in
2012 at the Republican National
Convention in Tampa but the hottest
piece of police surveillance technology
one is making headlines is called
stingray stingray is a device that
simulates a cell phone tower and it can
disrupt and reroute your connection so
the police know who you're contacting
when you're contacting them and a bunch
of other data the device can also read
your text messages look at your browsing
history and even listen to your phone
calls the scary thing is it isn't
targeted so you just have to be in the
vicinity of stingray and you're fair
game even if you're just at home playing
Angry Birds this kind of technology is
what the military uses to hunt groups
like Isis and al-qaeda and it's
distributed by the Department of
Homeland Security the FBI and in some
cases financed by the CIA so who are
police trying to target with all of this
technology sometimes they're criminals
murderers child pornographers
but police surveillance has
traditionally targeted two groups
minority communities and political
activists low-income african-american
communities are seeing a skyrocketing
number of police cameras in their
neighborhoods
and thanks to leaked documents we now
know that the NYPD was monitoring the
social media accounts of young black and
brown men for potential gang activity
and once you're on one of these lists
it's incredibly hard to get off
basically you're labeled a criminal
without even committing a crime in order
to track Muslim communities police use
license plate scanners to record who's
visiting a certain month they also use
geo mapping to target muslim-owned
businesses and religious institutions
and if you're an organizer activists you
probably know you're also being closely
watched cops have infiltrated black
lives matter organizing efforts around
the country
undercover police were discovered in
Oakland and in Chicago activists saw the
tell-tale sign of stingray which was a
black SUV and in the days following the
Baltimore protests over the death of
Freddie gray
small white surveillance planes could be
seen roaming the skies let all of that
sink in not only a federal agent
collecting our metadata through our
gadgets but we're under constant and
ever more advanced police surveillance
whether or not we're suspected of doing
anything wrong can all of this actually
prevent crime and at what cost and when
it comes to speaking out is surveillance
leading to self-censorship
[Music]